[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
r kelly's accusers take to the stand
saying they were sexually and physically
abused before escaping his defense not
holding back on cross-examination
what are you going to get from the
witness
you'll hear the r b singer now on trial
and the final radio call for a police
officer shot in florida it is with great
sadness that we announce the passing of
daytona beach police officer jason
raynor prosecutors now say they plan to
seek the death penalty for his accused
killer plus do not kill cathy robert
durst is back on the stand for another
round of cross-examination the questions
the denials and the jabs sitting here
it's funny
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm jesse weber in our studios brian
buckmeyer is on assignment at r kelly's
trial and with us as always is terry
austin one by one women are taking the
stand against the r b singer speaking
out about decades of allegations of sex
crimes now cameras aren't allowed in the
courtroom but brian is there to hear
their stories brian it's good to see you
let's start what did the first r kelly
accuser testify to
yeah so jeronda pace the first accuser
against r kelly testified just giving us
a lot of background that she met r kelly
first in uh when she was 14 in his 2008
chicago trial that she lied to get into
the trial saying that she was older than
she actually was
also talked about meeting him some about
13 months later when she was 16 and
that's when she was at his home
described the layout this mirror room
that she was in and then spoke about
that first encounter also spoke about
the another encounter when she showed up
to his house and put on a bikini at the
pool and walked back and forth at his
request taking off different pieces of
article clothing and then later having
sexual relations with him uh one of the
big points that came out as well was the
fact that he had asked her to put her
hair up in ponytails and dress like a
girl scout prior to having sex as well
as wearing a specific type of heels that
he allegedly liked her to wear during
sexual acts
wow and brian it's my understanding that
jaronda pace faced some very serious
questioning on cross-examination by the
defense what did you say
absolutely so they attacked her kind of
getting to the point of a few things one
that she's trying to make money off of
this of course we know that she has a
book that came out i believe that she
said that she made anywhere from 25 to
100 000 in that book also that she's
made uh some statements on youtube as
well as television and uh one part came
out that was a little bit comical for us
watching where the defense was trying to
point out a lie where she said on april
1st of 2008 she was 14 when she first
met r kelly then in may 2009 she was 16
and the defense was confused how a
person can age in two years and 13
months until she finally said my
birthday is april 19th so 18 days before
that i was 14 and then may of 2009 i was
16. that was a little intriguing for all
of us but also about this settlement one
of many that she had the first one being
that she signed a document along with
her mother saying that she told r kelly
she was 19 at the time and signed a
document to that point along with her
mother and also this issue of herpes
came up on cross-examination that was
intriguing to say because the defense
got out that at one point in time she
may have commented to the government
that r kelly mentioned or at least
alluded to the fact that she had herpes
and in fact actually checked her to see
if she did
yeah i want to get into that and there's
clearly a lot more to unpack here so
brian stand by it's not just what's
happening inside the court room it's
also what's happening outside because
fans have been showing their unwavering
support to r kelly but not everyone
there is standing behind him
i believe the parents because of
they stand now that these
alleged victims were underage okay
where were you at why did you not know
where your child was
you know it no it's gone and when you
see that he's brought them up
move the mic back please sir thank you
this is how much fan i am of mr robert
sylvester kelly to have tattoos put on
me
unfortunately with his celebrity dumb
i'm feeling he might get a slap on the
wrist
and um parents managers bodyguards
everyone involved producers who were in
the studios when this happened
should be charged with something you
know they
a lot has gone on and these children
they were children at the time i mean
i've seen photographs it's been all over
the news i've seen the documentary
produced by oprah winfrey and
it's so much evidence
but i really feel that he won't get
convicted
okay a lot of thoughts there terry let
me bring in how do these allegations by
jaronda pace fit into the racketeering
charge what are the underlying acts here
you know under the indictment the
underlying acts are the man act saying
that essentially she was transported and
she was used for sexual exploitation so
the indictment talks about the fact that
in july 2015
she was transported to kelly by actually
some of the employees brian mentioned
that she met kelly earlier but then a
year later she actually went and she had
sex with him and so she's saying that
she was obviously coerced that she was
taken there it was against her will she
as we know are talking about herpes
while she's on the stand so that is the
actual
you know allegation under the indictment
for the man act two acts the
transporting and the sexual coercion
yeah and the man act obviously a part of
that racketeering charge but brian you
had mentioned herpes terry just
mentioned as well how exactly did that
play out for pace well you should expand
upon that
yeah
so
it brought up because remember she's
bringing up the herpes allegations to
try and connect to another jane doe
who's going to probably testify later on
and the issue is not necessarily just
passing on the herpes but not informing
the individual this being jaronda pays
that r kelly had herpes beforehand now
first it came up by the the prosecution
and the direct but the defense
cross-examined her with a statement that
she had given to the government at one
of the interviews
that r kelly had brought up the fact
that herpes had been passing around his
group uh not necessarily saying that he
had it but that he wanted to check her
now it was kind of unclear whether or
not he said that if someone asked you
could tell people that i had herpes or
that you could not but the issue being
that he has to inform her somewhat of
herpes he kind of muddied the waters
there for the prosecution who would have
thought that this would be such a major
piece of evidence but it really is and
we're going to talk more about r kelly
so everybody stand by on that but
turning now to more top legal news
actress amber hurd lost her bid to
dismiss a lawsuit filed against her by
her ex johnny depp now depp is suing his
former wife in a virginia court the
pirates of the caribbean actor is
claiming that heard defamed him heard
has repeatedly said publicly that depp
was physically abusive during their
marriage in fact writing in an op-ed in
the washington post in 2018 that she was
a victim of domestic violence now heard
never named depp in that article
specifically but according to depp's
lawsuit it relied on the central premise
that depp quote perpetrated domestic
violence against her depp is suing her
for 50 million dollars
still ahead on law and crime daily the
tribute that officers are paying to one
of their own fallen on duty but first
more on r kelly how a tv series that
blew the lid on sex crimes allegations
could be impacting his criminal trial
our legal analysis next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
welcome back everybody back now to the
trial of r kelly where explosive
testimony is unfolding against the r b
singer we now know that jane doe number
four is the woman who's come forward as
jaronda pace r kelly is facing a slew of
charges in connection to pace's
accusations prosecutors are accusing the
singer of violating the man act and
racketeering they say that he
transported her across state lines and
coerced and enticed her into having sex
with him when she was a minor now pay
says r kelly was both physically and
psychologically abusive making her
believe that if she didn't follow his
commands she could face serious harm she
described one of those threats on the
lifetime docu-series surviving r kelly
i was a part of a suicide pad
if he was to go to jail
i was supposed to kill myself
and
i'm sorry i'm getting emotional
okay now brian it's my understanding
that she hasn't testified about this
suicide pact but
right she did testify about her diary
and is the show playing a role in this
trial as well
so the show is not specifically playing
a role in trial but it does come up from
time to time i think the defense is
trying to make the argument that she's
somehow profiting from the fame
or infamy depending on who you ask of
being with r kelly now to the diary the
prosecution brought up the diary to try
to pinpoint not only the allegations of
r kelly abusing her uh on that date but
also the day and specifically read one
part of the diary that i'm going to try
to quote as best i can quote i went to
rob's house and rob called me a silly
curse word rob slapped me three times he
said if i lied to him again it's not
going to be an open hand next time he
spit in my face and in my mouth he
choked me during an argument i had sex
with him had oral sex with him then i
became fed up and i went home and
confessed now that came out and that was
shocking to everyone the defense uh to
their some credit because they are i
think doing at least some good some bit
of a good job in painting her as a
stalker or a groupie based on her
answers and the testimony said that this
journal entry was on and this journal in
its entirety was only made after she met
with the lawyers and was trying to
remember the past not contemporaneously
so really back and forth blow for blow
in terms of the arguments presented by
either side terry obviously the
prosecution believes that she has some
compelling testimony when you talk about
the order of witnesses is that why she
was the first is that why i
strategically put her first
i think that it was a strategic move she
has some very strong evidence here not
the least of which is the fact that she
saved the semen from when they had that
sexual encounter it's on that blue shirt
she talked about i think also because
she was very young when she first met
him and i think that has an impact on
the jury she's also very credible
understand the fact that she cried when
she was reading the diary or the journal
entries i think that is going to have an
impact on the jury as well and you know
i think that she was nine months
pregnant sometimes it's logistics and
they may have wanted to get her in and
get her out before she has her baby yeah
that's just a practical concern brian
thank you so much great reporting as
always on this case and we're going to
talk more about it obviously as this
trial progresses but uh switching gears
it's time to check in with chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
coming up this week i'm brian ross
investigates another look at a still
unfolding spy mystery are the russians
targeting american cia officers and
diplomats with a mystery weapon that
emits a powerful high-energy wave that
can affect the brain it's called the
havana syndrome and we'll talk with one
of the americans who says he was
targeted december of 2017 and i woke up
in the middle of the night in a moscow
hotel and a five-star hotel just two
blocks from the u.s embassy and i woke
up with it with an incredible case of
vertigo um
you know tinnitus which is ringing in
the ears you know splitting headache i
felt like physically sick that's coming
up this week on brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
all right great stuff from brian ross
and coming up here on law and crime
daily robert durst under pressure why
the real estate air is now blaming his
wife's disappearance on her alleged drug
use plus
captured after a multi-state manhunt the
alleged shooter could now face the
highest penalty the new charges after
the wounded officer succumbs to his
injuries
[Music]
welcome back prosecutors in florida have
announced they plan to seek the death
penalty for a man accused of shooting an
officer law on crime's angenette levy's
here to explain why although wallace's
charges have now been upgraded hi
internet
hey jesse officer jason raynor sadly
passed away on tuesday evening two
months after he was shot the man up
accused of firing that fatal shot could
get the death penalty if he is convicted
now a massive manhunt led officials to
other wallace he was hiding in a tree
house in georgia in june the 29 year old
ran after police said he shot officer
raynor in the face when the officer was
questioning him at his vehicle the
treehouse where wallace was found is
reportedly affiliated with a black
nationalist paramilitary organization
wallace appeared at a hearing this week
where he said he wants to hire private
counsel
uh mr wallace is it your intention to
try to hire private counsel or do you
want to have the public veteran's office
represent
you like the public finished
representation
well for right now i'll point their
office obviously you'll have to pull out
a financial affidavit to make sure you
be qualified but for right now i'll
point you
now what you heard there was wallace
saying that he wants to hire his own
private attorney after officer raynor
died the charges against wallace were
upgraded to first degree murder and
prosecutors are going to seek the death
penalty jesse thanks angenet uh terry
the defendant you know has this
affiliation as angenette said with this
paramilitary organization how do you
think
that could be used against him at an
eventual trial
i think the prosecution is going to try
to say that wallace hated all authority
he hated police this is why he did what
he did and the name of the coalition
itself no effing around coalition that
really is an offensive name and it says
that its whole mission is to protect and
liberate black americans so i think
essentially one of the things that the
prosecution is really going to try to do
is to show that this defendant has this
background he has this affiliation and
he basically is acting out his hatred
and that's the motive behind the crime
and jeannette this is such a sad case
what did officer raynor's colleagues do
to honor him after he passed away
well jesse as we've seen so many times
before there really is an outpouring for
the from the law enforcement community
when one of their own dies in the line
of duty and this time was no different
there were officers from several
agencies that lined a procession route
and and really
led and followed
officer raynor's body from the hospital
to the funeral home several agencies
taking part as i mentioned including the
volusia county sheriff's office so it
was really
quite a sight to see all of those cars
lined up and the police officers
saluting him for one of his final rides
as they prepare for his funeral
it's always tough to cover these kinds
of cases and this is exactly that kind
of case but now it seems that they are
trying to find the ultimate penalty
against the man that they say committed
this atrocity and jeannette levy thank
you so much for reporting on this really
tough case
no problem when we come back robert
durst in his own defense is he lying on
the witness stand or is this untold
story really what explains his wife's
1982 disappearance inside that
california courtroom next
[Music]
welcome back everybody the
cross-examination of robert durst is
continuing and prosecutors are not
holding anything back robert durst is on
trial for the murder of his best friend
susan berman the real estate heir is
accused of killing berman because she
allegedly had information about durst's
missing wife kathy a death a death that
durst is also accused of on the stand
during direct durst alluded to the fact
that kathy could have disappeared
because of her alleged alleged drug use
but prosecutor john lewin believes
that's a tale that durst made up to
cover for his wife's murder
true mr durst that this cocaine
addiction narrative this is a concoction
you dreamed up
lied up manufactured
in order to explain the disappearance of
your wife kathy who you killed
captain
overruled
did not kill cassie
i did not dream up that she was doing
much too much cocaine
and the
testimony escalated from there with
durst claiming that kathy was enrolled
in a drug rehab at the very same
hospital that she was applying to for
her residency for when she graduated med
school the prosecution however didn't
buy it
mr durst
look what's number one
the program she wants to go to is lennox
hill hospital
oh she was already there
yes as a drug addict patient
let me understand this
i guess the interview would have gone
something like this dr durst what what
makes you
position that your life
chose lennox hill hospital to go to
rehab
and that was going to be
the number one
program she wanted to match for her
residency does that make sense to you at
all i think i need to congratulate you
you have just broken your personal
record you filled up 18 lines on my
tablet
and i want to congratulate you you set
the perjury record
oh boy uh terry you know lewin made this
great point about kathy not wanting to
work at the same hospital where she
attended rehab so what did you think
about durst's explanation
know durst was being very arrogant there
and i don't think it came across well
with the jury they went back and forth
of course lewin is trying to say she
would never apply to do a medical
residency anywhere that she was doing a
drug rehab and his claim is basically
that durst is making this up she did not
have a cocaine problem and durst is just
basically saying that this is the reason
she left because of the drugs and i
think his explanation was that lennox
hill is a great hospital it's in a rich
area and it's not a big problem if a
celebrity goes to that hospital and of
course they work there and they had a
drug rehab there but i think the jury is
going to see straight through that i
think they are listening to what lewin
is saying here i think it's an excellent
excellent point durst is absolutely
making up this cocaine issue we know for
a fact from the medical records that she
performed well in school and there's no
evidence here that she had a rehab
program so i definitely think that uh
lewin got the better end of that
argument terry let me ask you real quick
this combative back and forth is it
possible is it making durst look
sympathetic at all
maybe a little bit some people might
think that lewin is beating him up but i
think the fact that we're seeing durst
say things like we just heard in that
clip where he talks about the fact that
it was 18 lines long that's not
necessary and i think the jury's not
going to like that at all oh boy i can't
wait to see that jury deliberation what
a case what a case terry austin thank
you so much for everything and everyone
out there thanks for joining us here on
law and crime daily we're gonna see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america and cover the top cases that are
happening across this country we'll see
you next time here on law and crime
daily
[Music]
[Music]
you